the fertility industry is booming more
people than ever are having procedures
in the UK and the success rates too are
improving but fertility treatment is
unique in British healthcare because the
vast majority of patients are also
paying customers
new data from the human fertilization
and embryology Authority shows that
whilst the number of IVF treatments Rose
by nine percent between 2019 and 2021
the number carried out on the NHS
actually fell by 10 for patients aged 18
to 34 63 percent of IVF procedures are
now privately funded compared to 52
percent back in 2019
one of the major issues is ballooning
NHS waiting lists so typically a couple
would be trying to concede for two years
before going to see the GP the GP would
then send them for tests
um both male and female tests and and
some of these tests such as
laparoscopies they can take in some
parts of the country up to two years to
have that test and that's before you
actually then get referred to the
fertility clinic where they sometimes
can be additional delays so when you
considered that times of the essence
when it comes to fertility treatment
families too are changing the numbers of
single women and lesbian couples seeking
fertility treatment have risen sharply
but these two groups in particular can
struggle to access treatment on the NHS
and have to try other methods such as
manual insemination first to get the
funding the eligibility to the IVF is um
we have to have tries of IUI I think
it's three to six tries and we have to
prove that we've tried IUI treatment
before we're considered for IVF which
cost thousands of pounds again so
there's a huge barrier IVF was pioneered
here in Britain 45 years on it's
revolutionized fertility treatment but
more needs to be done to ensure the
benefits of that Revolution are equally
shared Matthew Thompson Sky News